Search gear for that. Is it? Hey,
what are your thoughts on net and tragedy?
Because I would talking to people online
today about net neutrality. Yeah. Uh,
I posted something about it that it seems
to me to be one of those ideological
camp issues where if
you are leaning right,
you think that net neutrality is a bad
thing, that the market should decide.
If you're leaning left,
you think that there's some regulation
that the government should step in and be
important because you want to
keep people from information.
You don't want to a big corporation to
be able to step in and say someone can or
can't have their program
on 18 t or Verizon or,
I think that from what I've read,
there are six major service providers.
Maybe,
maybe a couple more that that already
smelled a little bit like a monopoly.
But what I think is that if you and I,
first of all, nobody really knows yet,
but I think that the bigger issue becomes
if these companies provide you service
in your area,
they could decide to break it into say
to bandwidth say could decide you want
regular, you want regular
service or do you want premium?
If you want premium we're going to pay
a little more and that's one thing they
could bring it up. If that's the
case, we'll let the market decide.
Maybe that maybe that creates an opening
for another service provider to come in
and say, we don't do that
one price covers everything.
It's one of the guys on my Instagram
or my Twitter rather had a really good
point.
He said the real issue that people aren't
talking about is the monopolies that
these companies have in small areas.
Like if you're in a certain town,
like you can only get this kind of company
or Verizon or, that's what I'm saying.
When you have a company that owns
a certain town and then you know,
and in certain areas is the
only way you can get coverage.
Do you have to do with this one company,
then then it becomes a real issue.
And not only is it become an issue,
but the other issue is that now the
real question is if you are a service
provider and you provide, uh,
people in this area, that service,
if the other service has,
if you use platforms that the other
service provides and they compete directly
with this,
would this service block that,
would this service have
an incentive to uh,
slow block your access to it or whatever?
And that would be an issue. But my,
my feeling is that we'll find out very
quickly and as long as consumers have the
ability to go over to another provider,
as long as consumers
have the ability to go,
I don't like the way you do business, I
want, but they don't have gotten some,
a lot of areas becomes the
[inaudible] have a license,
they have a license in a certain,
a certain district consumer
backlash is how you fight that.
If there's enough consumer
backlash and people go,
are you just keeping it net neutrality
in place and prevent it, you know? Yeah.
I mean it's just I'm going to have some
experts on to talk about it soon in the
future. Yeah. I'm going over
all the data and information,
but I just wanted to get
people's temperature and
it's so funny how people, uh,
get so aggressive and shitty with you
when you just talk about this issue
because a few people, I had a mute.
I was like, good luck dude. Yup.
Your opinion means shit to me because
you just have to be insulting when
someone's just asking a question. Right.
You know this, this whole thing is,
is interesting because there's smart
people on both sides of it and they have
compelling arguments on both
sides of it and I don't,
I don't have an opinion
100% I lead more people.
A lot of people don't yet know how this
this is going to play out well because
you know where we may say though,
you lean towards what I lean towards
the idea that you have to have some
oversight, that you have to
have someone who's looking out,
who makes sure that these companies
can't fuck you over and can't prevent you
from having access to certain information.
Certain sites I lean towards that most,
but the answer that other,
the other question is though that does
the market decide that was going to say
the other oversight could be,
I always leaned toward the idea that
the marketplace would be your oversight.
Let people make their choice,
but they have to have a choice.
Unless you were talking about there
are very few service providers. My,
my question is,
is there incentive for other people to
come into the service providing space?
Can they make money?
Uh,
what are the barriers to entry and
as far as that's concerned, right.
And secondly, secondly, um,
is it in the service provider's interest
ultimately to make extra cash for such
bad press? I, you may see
nothing happened as a result,
but I liked the idea that the marketplace,
that consumers have a choice,
and when consumers have a choice,
they're going to go with what works
the best for Groupie. I do too.
But I do believe that it's
entirely possible that large
corporations could have
monopoly, real, real influence over the
way our culture has access to information.
I think I agree that should be stopped,
but I also think that these fucking
government organizations almost all suck.
They're all filled with unmotivated
people who suck at their job and the
bureaucracy and the fucking red
tape gets deeper and thicker.
I think almost every government
organization that does any task is flawed.
So the idea that we should have
government take care of these issues.
I have a problem with that too,
missy both sides of it.